Bitte schön.
Ich kann ja.
Bitte schön, ja.
Schönen guten Tag, his ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz-Tätich.
Und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmigesprech durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, sehr gerne, Doktor.
Sehr gut. Okay, kurz zum Ablauf.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Danach werde ich beschwerden kommen.
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Paul Klee.
Paul Klee. Können Sie bitte Ihre Nachname büchtern?
Nachname ist mit KL-E.
KL-E, ja.
Herr Klee. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 64 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
2. März 1960.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 1,75.
1,75.
1,75, also war ich mal.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zum Zeit?
Ich habe ein bisschen zugenommen jetzt im Urlaub.
Also so ungefähr 98 kg.
Was kann ich für ein Sektor?
Ja, Doktor, ich komme mit folgenden Beschwerden zu Ihnen.
Und zwar habe ich Schmerzen in meinem linken Bein.
Und seit ungefähr mehr, wo zwei, drei Tagen,
dann war ich beim Hausarzt und der hat gesagt,
ich soll doch mal ins Krankenhaus gehen,
weil er das nicht ganz einschätzen kann,
was dahinter versteckt ist.
Ich habe zuerst gedacht, das sind vielleicht Muskelkatter,
weil ich war letzte Woche noch im Urlaub gewesen.
Da habe ich ein bisschen auch Sport gemacht,
also Fitness und so, was ich noch mal auch nicht kann.
Und habe gedacht, das ist jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen
von der Überanstrengung.
Aber es wird nicht besser.
Und das Problem ist, also es sind Ziendeschmerzen im Bein.
Und jetzt aktuell ist es auch seit gestern das Bein etwas dicker.
Und auch ein bisschen wärmer als das andere Bein.
Ich schulde, ich muss kurz unterbüchern.
Seit wann habe Sie bemerkt, Ihre Bein geschworen ist?
Seit gestern etwa.
Seit gestern.
Seit gestern war ich geschworen.
Linker Bein, ja.
Ja, linker Bein.
Okay.
So sicher, muss ich noch mal fragen,
wie sind Ihre Schwärmen aufgetreten?
Also wie gesagt, das ist etwa so 3 Tage,
habe ich halt dieses Muskelkatter,
dieses Schmerz in dem Bein.
Also langsam zu nehmen?
Ja, etwa, ja.
Ist auch nicht so stark der Schmerz, aber...
Aber auf einmal.
Ja, jetzt, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen
auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sei leichter Schmerz
und 10 am stärksten Schmerz ist.
Also 2, 3 würde ich sagen.
Ja.
Nicht so schlimm.
Wie meinen Sie?
Ich meine nur im Bein.
Nur im Bein.
Keine Ausstöle bis zu Fußsohle.
Ach so, das geht nach unten, ja, bis in die Wade, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder verschwindet sie seitweiser?
Die verschwindet komplett, aber werden manchmal etwas weniger,
also ist nicht immer gleich.
Aber immer da, sagen Sie?
Ja, auch wenn es mal weniger ist, ist nie ganz weg, ja.
Gibt es Auslöse für Ihr Schmerzen?
Kann ich so nicht sagen, also ich habe gedacht,
dass vielleicht wenn ich laufe mehr wird,
auch manchmal im Liege, also kann ich so nicht sagen.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihr Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Kann ich auch nicht sagen, Doktor.
Also manchmal denke ich, wenn ich das Bein,
das ist mit dem Liegen, besser, aber manchmal auch nicht.
Okay, danke für die Information.
Ich will fragen,
haben Sie Überkeit oder Erbrechen oder Kartanschweiß bemerkt?
Überkeit oder Erbrechen nicht.
Und das letzte war nochmal etwas, ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden.
Kartanschweiß oder Nachtschweiß bemerkt?
Ah, Kartanschweiß, nein, also habe ich nicht, nein.
Ist Ihnen Störfrost oder Fieber aufgefallen?
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Sturrgang oder bei Masalassen?
Ich habe vor sechs Wochen eine Operation in der Prosta gehabt.
Und seitdem habe ich, also ich habe danach erst mal ein Katheter gehabt,
eine Woche lang.
Und da ist immer noch nicht so normal.
Ja, ein Katheter wurde angelegt.
Nach der Operation wurde der Katheter angelegt.
Okay.
Danke sehr.
Danke sehr. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit zugenommen oder abgenommen?
Ich habe zugenommen mit dem Urlaub, glaube ich, ein bisschen.
Ich habe etwas mehr gegessen als sonst, glaube ich, ja.
So zwei, drei Kilogramm.
Wie sieht Ihr Schlaf aus?
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen, durchzuschlafen?
Normalerweise sind ich jetzt in den letzten Tagen
vielleicht durch die beschwerden Beinen etwas Durchschlafstörungen,
aber sonst früher nicht eigentlich.
Schlafprobleme wegen Schmessen im Bein?
Ja, sonst aber keine Probleme mit dem Schlafen.
Ja.
Und haben Sie Atemnot bemerkt oder?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe so ein bisschen, glaube ich,
weil ich zugenommen habe, habe ich ein bisschen,
merke ich, dass, wenn ich jetzt Treppen steige,
so ein bisschen schneller aus der Prosta komme, ja.
Aber erst ab dem Urlaub jetzt, in letzter Woche.
Aber das liegt daran, dass ich zugenommen habe,
es ist oft so, weil mir nicht zunehme, dann drückt es nach oben.
Okay.
Ja, alles klar.
Jetzt habe ich Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte.
Gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Vorgeschichte,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Also wie gesagt, das war diese Operation an der Prosta
da gewesen vor sechs Wochen.
Das war auch ein kleiner Krebs, hat der Doktor gesagt.
Also nichts, was größer war, aber das war
ein Frühstadium von Prosta da Krebs.
Und das war, das wurde vor sechs Wochen etwa,
sechs, sieben Wochen.
Und das habe ich noch für Krankheiten.
Ich habe...
Wo diese vorstandig behandelt für diese Krebs?
Also mit Operationen, ja.
Also ich brauche keine Nachbarnung, hat der Doktor gesagt.
Und also ich habe Reflux-Probleme und also schon seit vielen Jahren.
Da bin ich auch am Magen mal operiert worden,
aber das ist immer noch ein Problem mit Reflux.
Dann ist bei mir eine COPD festgestellt worden,
deswegen nehme ich auch Spreys ein.
Und der Doktor sagte mal vor einigen Jahren,
dass ich immer mal dicke Beine in dicke Füße hatte,
dicke Unterscheidung hatte,
dass bei mir eine gewisse Herzschwäche auch vorliegt,
hat er mir damals Medikamente gegeben.
Ich muss hier kurz unterhalten.
Warum dann diese Krankheiten festgestellt worden?
Diese COPD habe ich schon seit ungefähr zehn Jahren,
nämlich seit...
Zehn Jahren?
Ja.
Reflux, schon seit über 15 Jahren.
Über 15, 20 Jahre schon.
Und auch die Operation ist auch schon jetzt mittlerweile 12 Jahre her, glaube ich.
Ja.
Und dieser Herzprobleme?
Das ist vor zwei, drei Jahren mal festgestellt worden.
Als Verdachtdiagnose ist das Herz gleich ein bisschen überlastet manchmal.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Das sonst noch verschiedene Opes,
würden Sie schon mal anderen Open?
Ja, das wären die Operationen, die ich hatte.
Nun habe ich keine weitere Operation.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergien und Unverteidigkeiten?
Sind keine bekannte Doktoren.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie regelmäßig,
nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Oder bei Bedarf gibt es Medikamente?
Ja, ich nehme für dieses Cepheridespiriva ein.
Bitte nochmal, Spiri.
Spiri war das, ja.
Und dann habe ich...
Wie viel Milligramm nehmen Sie?
Alles klar.
Ich habe jetzt die Packung nicht dabei, weiß ich nicht.
Ich nehme immer morgens zwei Hübe von diesem Medikament.
Nur als morgens nehmen Sie?
Ja.
Und dann nehme ich fast durchgehendes Pantoprazol ein.
Wenn ich keine besperren habe, lasse ich es auch mal weg.
40 Milligramm nehmen Sie?
40 Milligramm.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Also einmal pro Tag, bei Bedarf.
Selten als zweimal.
Ja.
Danke.
Und dann nehme ich noch für das Herz, dieses Bisoprolol.
Dann nehme ich morgens in den Abend eine Tablette.
Ich glaube, es müssten 2,5 Milligramm sein.
Ich muss noch mal nachgucken.
3,5 Milligramm morgens.
Morgen sind es abends, nehme ich die.
Abends.
Wenn die Beine dick werden, hat der Arzt mir
ein Medikament aufgeschrieben, das heißt, Thorazemith.
Ich nehme das mal bei Bedarf ein.
Okay.
Danke sehr.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie rauchen, Herr Klir.
Ja, ich rauche schon seit meinem 18. Lebensjahr, glaube ich.
18, ne?
Das ist schon viel.
Ja, das habe ich angefangen und habe es verreduziert,
aber ich habe mich nie aufkompet aufhören können.
Wie viel rauchen Sie?
Aktuell ein halbes Päckchen.
Ich habe früher mal ein Päckchen, aber ich habe es schon lange auf
ein halbes Päckchen reduziert.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also selten.
Wenn bestimmte Anlässe sind.
Also bestimmte Anlässe.
Trinken Sie Alkohol.
Was trinken Sie?
Also einen Wein oder ein Bier.
Einmal 2 Mal im Monat.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich muss diese Frage stellen.
Das ist nur eine Routine Frage.
Bitte nehmen Sie sich nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drocken ein?
Nein.
Ich gehe sehr gut.
Das freut mich.
Sind Sie vorstellig geimpft?
Das weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Wenn Sie Corona meinen, ja, damals vor 2 Jahren habe ich
alle drei Impfungen gehabt, aber andere Impfungen
haben sich nicht geimpft.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe jetzt keine.
Okay.
Sind Sie in Western-Zeit verreist?
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, ich habe im Urlaub.
Ja, in Urlaub.
Ich habe 10 Tage in Spanien.
Und ja, bin ich letzte Woche zurückgekommen.
Okay.
Jetzt habe ich einige Fragen.
Besonders Ihre Familienvorgeschichte.
Neben Ihrer Eltern noch, Herr Küll.
Mein Vater ist gestorben.
Die Mutter lebt noch.
Woran ist Ihr Vater gestorben?
Er hat Herzinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt, ja.
Wann wurde er gestorben?
Oh, es sind auch schon so 8, 9 Jahre.
Und Ihre Mutter, leiden Ihre Mutter an wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ja, die hat zu tun mit Zucker,
Brutdruck und Arthrose.
Ja, so die verschiedenen Alterskrankheiten.
Ja.
Okay.
Habt ihr sie geschwistert?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Nein, Sie sind Einzelkind.
Okay.
Herr Küll, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin in der IT-Branche.
IT-Branche.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet oder ledig?
Ich habe zwei Kinder, die schon erwachsen sind.
Okay.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Keine Krankheiten, wie es von Bedeutung werden.
Danke sehr für die Information.
Mir ist gerade einige Fragen aufgefallen.
Ich will diese Fragen stellen.
Ich habe sie in Ruhe oder bei Belastung?
Beides.
Ja, so, in Ruhe, also auch in Belastung?
Ja, richtig.
Und da auch.
Da auch, ja.
Habt ihr Farbeferenderingen oder Temperaturanderung bemerkt?
Ich war ein bisschen wärmer, hatte ich gesagt am Anfang.
Es ist ein bisschen wärmer als andere Beine, ja, das stimmt.
Ja.
Aber von der Farbe ist ungefähr gleich, also habe ich nichts gemerkt.
Sie haben keine Atemprobleme noch, oder?
Sie haben bestätigt, dass Sie keine Atemprobleme haben,
aber ein bisschen wegen dieser Anstieg bemerkte ich noch.
Ich habe zugenommen mit Simola, aber das bin ich aus der Puste,
wenn ich die Treppen steige, das stimmt, ja.
Ich habe eine solche Informationen mit dieser Frage.
Bin ich durch?
Wenn Sie etwas zum Fragen haben, Sie können.
Ja, was denken Sie, Doktor, muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Oder was denken Sie?
Ja, nach den bisherigen Angaben, die Sie mir gegeben haben,
ich gehe von einer Verschlusskrankheit in tiefen Wehnen.
Deswegen, Sie sollten für ein paar Tage bei uns
weitere Untersuchungen und Behandlungen bleiben.
Ich würde gerne Ihre körperliche Untersuchung machen bei Ihnen.
Ich würde gerne Ihre körperliche Untersuchung machen
und mit Doppler-Ultroson Ihre Gefäße überprüfen,
ob Ihre Gefäße noch offen sind.
Okay, was machen Sie da?
Müssen Sie da operieren oder wie machen Sie das?
Ich würde gerne Ihre körperliche Untersuchung machen
und mit Doppler-Ultroson oder Schall.
Okay, das ist einfache Untersuchung.
Das tut ja nicht weh, oder?
Ja, es ist ganz schmerzlos.
Es ist ganz schmerzlos und strahlend los.
Ist das etwas gefährlich, Doktor? Soll ich meine Frau anrufen?
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Sie sich so gerne machen.
Aber ich versichere Ihnen, dass Sie in guten Händen sind.
Wir können jederzeit ergreifen, wenn etwas Schlechtes auftreten.
Aber bitte erst mal machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Es gibt nichts Schlechtes derzeit.
Sie erwarten nicht, dass jetzt etwas Schlimmes passiert?
Ja.
Ok, gut.
Herr Doktor, ich habe eine Patientenverfügung.
Wollen Sie die haben oder wie machen Sie das?
Da steht drin, wenn etwas Schlimmes passiert,
dann möchte ich Sie nicht machen.
Soll ich diese Patientenverfügung nicht geben?
Ich habe eine Patientenverfügung.
Da steht drin, dass ich, wenn ich zum Beispiel an die Maschine gänke,
wenn ich bewusstlos werde, nicht wiederbelebt werden möchte.
Und auch nicht an die Maschine gänke.
Das würde ich gerne mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Da eine Frage in meinem Kopf noch steht.
Aber ich werde gleich wieder da, bitte nehmen Sie im nächsten Zimmer Platz.
Und machen Sie Ihre Beine frei, damit wir mit den Untersuchungen anfangen können.
Alles klar.
Vielen Dank für die Informationszahlen.
Auf Wiedersehen. Tschüß.
Danke schön.
So, gibt es Fragen, Kommentare aus dem Chat?
Hallo Herr Klie.
Hallo.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit auf der Wiese oder im Wald geblieben?
Was ist mein letzter Zeit?
Letzte Woche?
Monat?
Ja, in der letzten ein Monat oder so.
Wiese, da war ich nicht im Wald.
Das war ja auch noch nicht Frühling.
Also nein, war ich nicht im Wald.
Haben Sie in der Unterchenkel Haarausfall bemerkt?
Unterchenkel Haarausfall, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Zwei Fragen.
Bitte schön.
Noch eine, ich möchte legen.
Okay, immer zwei Fragen per Person.
Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage.
Herr Klie, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass der betroffene Bein ist dicker als die andere?
Ja, habe ich am Anfang gesagt und hat der Doktor auch geschrieben, glaube ich.
Okay, und werden Sie an den Waden drücken?
Ist das weh?
Hab ich nicht probiert.
Okay, danke, das war meine Frage.
Weiterer Fragen, Kommentare.
Ist jemand von außen, der etwas fragen möchte?
Nein, ich habe viele Fragen, aber Kollegen, ich walte.
Alles klar.
Also, ich schuldigung, der Doktor hat mir noch nicht gesagt, was das ist, also Verdachtdiagnose.
Hat er gesagt, doch, Verschluss hat er gesagt.
Ja, Verschluss, Krankheit.
Okay, weitere Fragen, oder die Sie den Patienten fragen wollten oder Kommentare.
Könnten Sie mich mal genau beschreiben, sind Sie eher dumpf, sich anbrennen und so weiter?
Du ziehend, eher so dumpf ziehend, würde ich beschreiben.
Hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal?
Nein, hatte ich nicht.
Sie haben gesagt Prostata, okay.
Nach der Behandlung, werte Behandlung haben Sie eingenommen, zum Beispiel über Therapie und so weiter.
Prostatektomie.
Prostatektomie und eine medikamentöse Therapie.
Keine.
Gibt es Kraftverlust, oder?
Kein Kraftverlust, nein.
Also, sind man ja so sensormotorische Störungen, ja.
Ja, danke.
Keine sensormotorischen Störungen, ja.
Wie viele Meta laufen Sie, bevor Sie stehen bleiben oder?
Früher, ohne Probleme, keine Einschränkung.
Okay.
Aber jetzt wegen Schmerzen laufe ich nicht mehr.
Prostata.
Wie viele Kissen mehr sind zum Schlafen?
Ein Kissen nur.
Okay.
Ich denke, eine Frage nicht, das ist auch ein einfacher Fall, glaube ich, ein ziemlich klarer Fall.
Ich will nur...
Einmal dich, das wollte ich etwas sagen.
Ich wollte sagen, dass es gibt einen Verschluss in der Tiefe von tiefen Wehnen.
Das heißt, ich dachte, die Tiefe wären Trombose erst mal.
Ja, das wird auch so.
Weil die Beine wärmer sind und rückschmerzhaft, Sie haben gesagt.
Nach der Beine, Arsatzgespräche.
Okay.
Dann machen wir Arsatzgespräche, würde ich sagen.
Wir haben noch viele Sachen zu besprechen beim Arsatzgespräch.
Okay, dann legen wir los.
Ich bin ein Schubarzt und Sie stellen Patienten vor.
Ja, Herr Oberhass, ich habe einen Patient, Herr Paul Klee,
der ich aufgenommen habe, er ist 64 Jahre alt am 2. März,
19, 64 Geboren, ein Meta 75 groß und 98 kg schwer übergewichtig Patient.
Er hat sich wegen seit vier Tagen bestehender, progredierender,
persisterender, langsam zu nehmen, der Schmerz im linken Bein
mit Ausstrahlung in die Hustle.
Die Schmerzen seien dunf und sichern.
Auf Schmerzskala würden die Schmerzen bei vier liegen.
Zwei bis drei.
Ja, linkes Bein sei wärmer geworden.
Es gibt eine Verdigung unter sich zwischen beiden Beinen.
Und an vegetativ anemnähe,
gab es eine Unauffälligkeit bis auf Wasser lassen
wegen Prostatvergrößerung, wegen der Prostatvergrößerung,
die damals ein Katheter angelegt wurden.
Und sie wurden bei ihm Prostatkrebs diagnostiziert.
Und vorerkrankungen leidet er an das Rheflux-Krankheiten.
Dafür nimmt sie Pantoprosol bei Bedarf ein.
Und er ist am Magen operiert worden.
Darüber hinaus leidet er an COPD vor zehn Jahren.
Wenn ich es nur erbreche, wissen Sie, was am Magen operiert worden ist
beim Patienten?
Nein Prozent.
Was ist operiert worden am Magen? Haben Sie gefragt oder wissen Sie das?
Ich weiß nicht.
Mir fanden zwei Sachen ein.
Bei Rheflux hatte er auch ein Ulcus.
Das Ulcus ist übernäht worden.
Oder er hat wegen Rheflux eine Fundobligat...
Ich würde sagen, aber jemand hat das schon geschrieben.
Er leidet an COPD.
Und für das ist er am Morgen bei Bekannten 1 mg ein.
Und für das ist er pro Löl 2,5 mg.
Am Morgen und Abendabend für dicke Beine ein.
Und für das ist er am Morgen bei Bekannten 1 mg ein.
2,5 mg.
Am Morgen und Abendabend für dicke Beine.
Er nimmt mit bei Bedarf ein.
Er raucht mit 18. Lebensjahr.
Das entspricht 23 Packages.
Er spielt das 2 Packages.
Nein, das kann man nicht.
Er hat gesagt, wir haben eine halbe Package.
Aber früher haben wir nicht gefragt.
Wir haben gesagt, ein Package.
Wenn man halbe oder halbe macht,
dann kann man sagen, 20 mal 1 Package.
20x10 und 30x30, würde ich sagen bei mir.
Wie viele Jahre? 46 Jahre, glaube ich.
46 Jahre, aber...
Wenn Sie ungefähr machen müssen, können Sie nicht genau machen, dann würde ich sagen,
die Hälfte, einen Päckchen pro Tag, also 20 Jahre, 20 Päckchen ist.
Und dann die Hälfte, 20 Jahre halbes Päckchen, das sind 10 Päckchen, dann ungefähr circa 30 Päckchen, oder mindestens 30.
Er ist Corona geimpft, aber er konnte nicht daran erinnern, was verständlich geimpft ist, oder nicht?
Er war vor 10 Tagen in Spanien.
Er ist in der Erfurt gestorben, vor 9 Jahren.
Er ist in der IT-Branche und verheiratet und hat 2 Kinder.
Nach dem bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von tiefwehenen Thrombose aus.
Dafür sollte ich erst mal körperliche Untersuchungen machen.
Ganz kurz bevor Sie weitermachen, das ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose.
Was denken Sie, gibt es für Differenzialdiagnosen bei den Patienten?
Perfekt, arteriale Verschlusskrankheit.
Was spricht dagegen?
Ich würde kalte Beine erwarten und eine geschütte Recke erst mal hören.
Was gibt es noch für Differenzialdiagnosen, die Ihnen einfallen?
Das ist ein Differenzialdiagnose, das ist ein wichtiges.
Was ist noch?
Das ist ein wichtiges.
Bevor wir zur Diagnostik gehen, welche Angaben oder Informationen aus der Anase machen?
Er hatte vorher Krebsfalle und er ist 64 Jahre alt.
Er hat geschuldene Extremität und druckschmerzhafte Beine.
Also Klinik, ja.
Also alter Krebsklinik, was haben Sie noch für einem lässigen Angaben,
die das wahrscheinlich machen, das mit der Krebserkrankstun hat?
Vielleicht Betzlagerigkeit, das könnte sein.
Die OP, die Voroperation.
Krebserkrankung und Operation, das ist ein Risikofaktor in der Trombose.
Wir haben geschuldene Extremität, vielleicht gesagt.
Das ist klinisch, ich würde jetzt nur an einem lässigen Angaben wissen von Ihnen.
Was gibt es noch für einen anderen Missingangelang, die Sie in Richtung TVT denken lassen?
Hat noch ein paar, möchte ich von Ihnen hören, was noch Risikofaktoren sind?
Oder Hinweise geben könnten?
Ich konnte nicht finden, dass ich steht vor mir, aber...
Denken Sie mal an eine Begleiterkrankung?
Bitte?
Ja, er hat, heißt das Instanz und COPD.
Das sind auch Risikofaktoren, also die hat eine Wissen über die auch wissen.
Was gibt es noch für Informationen aus einer Schilderung, die das wahrscheinlich machen lassen?
Schilderung, Sie haben eine dünne Schmerzung.
Reise.
Nicht beklatscht.
Das ist eine Flugreise, da gibt es auch einen bestimmten Begriff, den man mit Flugreisen und Trombosen zusammenbringen kann.
Kennen Sie den Begriff?
Ja, natürlich.
Er war ihm vielleicht in einer Flug, das könnte ein bisschen dauern.
Genau, er ist also nicht bis in das Glas geflogen, sondern...
Das leutet ein Immobilisiertate auf.
Kennen Sie den Begriff?
Economik-Klas-Findrom.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Also Reise, genau.
So, was haben wir noch für Risikofaktoren?
Sonst haben wir, glaube ich, die wichtigsten.
Eine Sache habe ich noch, die mir noch einfällt.
Bei ihm aus der Anamnese.
Was ist denn, sag ich mal, die Pathophysiologie an der Trombose?
Ja, ich glaube, da gibt es einen deutschen Arzt, der ganz wichtig, der drei Sachen gesagt hat.
Ja, Waschhochtrees, meine Sie, ich verstehe.
Ich auch, Kreas, ja, genau.
Kennen Sie die, wie man sich kreiert?
Ja, auf Deutsch wird es ein bisschen schwierig sein, aber Veränderung der, ich würde sagen, Veränderung der Gefäßinnenwand,
Entsündung der Trauma.
Ja.
Und dann, wo man die Blut, die Sudamusetung,
oder die Naigung zur,
Viskosität,
Blutfletschen,
und dann, wo man die Blutstromp stört.
Genau, also Stase, Viskosität und Nutellschaden, genau.
Ja, richtig.
Ja, kennen Sie Sachen, die die Viskosität im Blut erhöhen,
dass sich die Trombose naigung?
Ja, ja, richtig.
Was zum Beispiel?
Viskosität, was erhöht diese Flugreise zum Beispiel, diese Immobilisation,
oder manche Krankheiten, oder Dehydratation, ja, ja,
Ja, das ist richtig.
Längen Sie mal an seine Medikamente, die er nimmt?
Haben Sie da eins, was das macht?
Manche Medikamente zum Beispiel, Bysoprol,
ja, der Porosemit, natürlich.
Ja, Porosemit, Theoretikum, man hat auch Trombose-Risiko,
erhöht Trombose-Risiko, alles klar.
Gut, jetzt haben wir praktisch die anermäßigen Angaben
auf Trombose erfasst, also es sprechen viele Sachen dafür,
dass es eine Trombose ist.
Jetzt gibt es noch ein paar klinische Zeichen, die wollten Sie mir erwähnen,
was kann man denn machen, um das festzustellen, klinisch?
Ja, nach der köpferlichen Untersuchung würde ich noch etwas mit der Bestimmung der DEMAS.
Was ist denn Köpferichner suche bei Trombons Verdacht bei Ihnen?
Was machen Sie da?
Also, ja, Inspektion, natürlich, ich sehe eine geschwollene Beine,
geschwollene Beine und mit Perpation, ich kann fühlen,
dass er wärmes Bein hat.
Ja, genau.
Und mit Lobo-Untersuchung, mit der Bestimmung der DEMAS.
Wer hat die Zeichen gibt?
Ja, das kommen wir gleich.
Jetzt gibt es noch klinische Zeichen und Untersuchungen, diese Testen.
Ja, beide können das so machen.
Da Sie neue Examen gemacht haben, neue Frischen, müssen Sie es wissen.
Also, man muss durch die Frage nicht mehr, weil es bei Ihnen schon lange her ist.
Da kann es aber auch bestimmt, aber bei jungen Ärzten, die müssen das noch wissen, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, nicht.
Ja, es gibt klinische Zeichen.
Ja, es gibt viele Zeichen mit dieser Bewegung der Fuß.
Ja, welches?
Das ist der Hohmann Zeichen.
Oder das ist der Peir Zeichen.
Was ist Hohmann?
Hohmann ist, wenn ich den Fuß nach...
Das ist der Hohmann Zeichen.
Was ist Peir?
Das ist der andere Art von...
Vielleicht sollte ich den Fuß in die gegenseitige Bein führen.
Kenn ich nicht.
Also, Peir Zeichen, wenn Sie die Fußsohlen schmerzproduzieren können, ja.
Das ist Peir Zeichen.
Und da gibt es noch einen Zeichen, das ist Peir Zeichen, wo man Wadenburgschmerz auslösen kann.
Aber ich habe es richtig gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob es vielleicht auch nicht mehr ganz parat ist.
3 Zeichen, das sind die klinischen Zeichen.
Gut, da wir so jetzt beim Examen sind, kennen Sie auch so einen klinischen Score,
wie man die Thrombose-Wahrscheinlichkeit hervorragend fragen kann?
Ich habe schon überfällt, wer das Score gespürt.
Ja, jemand möchte immer schreiben.
Nein, reicht mir schon. Ich kann auch nicht mehr Weltscore auswendig.
Das müssen Sie dann, wenn Sie gefragt werden, sagen.
Also, der hat jetzt praktisch von dem Weltscore auch einen hohen Score,
dass das Wahrscheinlichkeit für Thrombose da ist.
Jetzt kommen wir zu den weiteren operativen und laborisch chemischen diagnostischen Maßnahmen.
Was machen Sie?
Also, ich wollte immer die Daime sagen.
Als Bildgeber in der Verfahrung würde ich natürlich,
das ist die Problem bei den Dedimären, das bei diesen Patienten.
Dedimer ist relay, in uns so verlasslich eigentlich.
Das heißt, wenn es positiv ist, dann wird es nicht.
Aber wenn es positiv ist, dann müssen wir weitere Erachtungen gestören,
so wie Fatuplex, so eine Große.
Warum kann bei dem Patienten Dedimer positiv sein, auch ohne Thrombose?
Weil er geschohlene Beine hat und COPD hat.
Kenn ich jetzt nicht, aber eine Sache aus einer Krankheitsgeschichte,
die ist vielleicht relevant, könnte sein.
Prostate, Katz, also Malignoma,
dann Malignoma insgesamt können spontane Flügelung,
also Flügellüse auslösen, Dedimer machen, könnte sein.
Das könnte nicht sein für die neue Information, für mich.
Ja, also Prostate, Malignoma machen oft Dedimer,
ohne akute Thrombowen.
Ja, ja.
Okay, und dann machen Sie jetzt Doppler oder Ultraschein, haben Sie gesagt.
Wie machen Sie das?
Das ist ein Ultraschallist,
eine Bilkierbende-Verfahren, damit wir
eine WN-Hörbar machen,
die WN-Quasi-Hörbar
werden.
Wir können verstehen, ob WN noch offen ist,
oder ob es eine Opfer gibt,
die eine Opfer hat,
die man auch durch die Thrombose entscheiden kann.
Also Sie leben in den Farbdoppel rein,
wenn Sie keinen Signalen haben, dann ist das Hinweis auf Doppler.
Was gibt es noch bei dem Ultraschall,
auch wenn Sie jetzt mal in der Praxishaushalts,
Sie haben keinen Farbdoppler,
was können Sie noch mal mit dem Ultraschall gucken,
wenn Sie nicht ganz sicher sind?
Es gibt zwei Doppler, eine...
Also, ich meine, Doppler haben wir gemacht,
das ist klar, aber wenn Sie jetzt keinen Doppler haben,
dann ist das ja ein Ultraschall,
das geht ohne Dopplerfunktion.
Was können Sie noch machen?
Ich würde abpassen,
oder mit Statoscope hören,
oder vielleicht über was meinet,
dass ich nicht mit Statoscope hören.
Ich kann verstehen, damit,
mit Statoscope, es gibt keinen Fluss mehr.
Bei der WN, das hören Sie nicht.
Das hören Sie nicht.
Dann kriegen Sie Nobelpreis, wenn Sie das hören.
Aber Sie können mit einem normalen Ultraschall
ohne Dopplerfunktion
eine Kompression urteilen,
ob komprimierbar oder nicht komprimierbar.
Normalerweise ist eine WN komprimierbar,
wenn Sie Druck ausüben.
Wenn Sie das nicht komprimieren können,
könnte es Hinweis sein, auch mit Rombose.
Wenn Sie zum Beispiel keinen Doppler haben
oder Doppler-Signal nicht so gut ist,
weil der Patient sehr dick ist,
können Sie ihm auch mit Kompressionssonographie
versuchen, festzustellen, ob die WN offen ist.
Wenn die WN sehr ungünstig liegt,
meistens mit Ultraschall, aber es gibt WN,
die man manchmal nicht gut beurteilen kann,
zum Beispiel Klavier oder Bariocephaliga
oder andere WN.
Welche Methoden gibt es noch, um
um Rombose festzustellen, außer Ultraschall?
Das sollte mich erst mal daran erinnern.
Ich erinnere mich mit einem WN-Bruf,
aber ich habe die Idee,
dass man kontrastmittel spritzt.
Oder Sie machen eine Angiografie, CT-Angiografie
mit Subtraktionen,
können Sie auch manchmal WN beurteilen.
Nur als Alternative, aber wie Sie es schon gesagt haben,
das ist das Method der Wahl des Ultraschall.
Doppler und Kompressionssonographie.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie die WN-Bruf,
die Sie in der Hand haben,
und das ist der Kompressionssonographie.
Jetzt haben Sie die WN-Bruf festgestellt,
was machen Sie mit den Patienten,
bleibt dem nach Hause?
Erst im Jahr der Therapie,
Konkursionstherapie und Mobilisation,
Anti-coagulant-Gabe.
Man könnte nicht mit Medikamente behandelt
sein,
Also selten der Fall, wenn es ganz frisch ist oder ganz schwere Komplikation ist, dann kann man versuchen mit lokalen Atombektonie,
nicht aber manchmal Lüse.
Bitte?
Keine Atombektonie.
Lüse, Lüse kann man manchmal machen, aber auch selten notwendig.
Also wenn sehr hohe Komplikationen sind, zum Beispiel massive Beschwellung oder Atterien-Embulie, Lungen-Embulie oder andere Komplikationen,
dann kann man, wenn es frisch ist, versuchen mit Lüse zu arbeiten.
Ansonsten haben Sie recht Antikorkulation. Womit machen Sie Antikorkulation in der Regel?
Im Regal. Hier bei dem 50 Milligramm?
Ja, also Niedermolkularseparien, das meiste Lust.
Gut, wie lange machen Sie die Blutverdienung Antikorkulation bei den Patienten?
Also diese klinische Information, ich besitze über diese klinische Information eigentlich.
Also ja, die Ausgehendromose ist normalerweise 3 Monate, ja?
Bei dem Rezediv müssen Sie sich überlegen und bei Komplikationen.
Jetzt sind wir bei Komplikationen. Was sind denn die Komplikationen von Tombose?
Es könnte Ulzer, Gangtra entstehen.
Selten, ja, kann es mal sein. Wissen Sie, wie das heißt?
Komplikation?
Ja.
Patient hat Dispner gesagt.
Das bedeutet Lungenembolie, natürlich.
Lungenembolie ist das Hauptrisiko, genau.
Ich dachte erst mal, ich betrachte meinen Bein, aber...
Es gibt selten mal, es gibt die Plegmasiakorea dolens.
Also das ist eine Komplikation, die selten ist, ja?
Also mit zusätzlichem materiellen Verschluss.
Aber es ist selten, Hauptkomplikation ist Lungenembolie, ist richtig.
Und deswegen machen Sie auch Anticoagulation.
Und zweite Komplikation, also eine weitere Komplikation,
die er jetzt nicht Akkus in einen Kron nicht auftreten kann.
Was ist das Problem bei solchen Patienten?
Also er hat schon ein TFT-Geschichte,
deswegen kann es immer noch weitere TFT-Fälle auftreten.
Richtig, also Rezediv, Tombose Rezediv, genau.
Und was kann noch passieren, wenn die Seiken durch die Tombose,
die durch Blödungen gestört ist?
Erstmal hat er gesagt bei Transialdiagnose.
Hat er gesagt, Posttropotis und Traum, gell?
Genau, also packt sich jetzt trophische Störungen auf der Haut zum Beispiel.
Deswegen ist es auch wichtig, frühzeitig auch mit Kompressionsverdraht zu versorgen.
Gut, das haben wir das wichtigste, glaube ich, abgehangen, oder?
Ich habe hier eine Frage, in meiner Anämnese,
haben Sie mir etwa eine Frage gestritten, aber das habe ich nicht verstanden,
dass ich sagte, ich werde mich nicht veröffentlichen.
Also bei so einem Patienten ist es natürlich die große Ausnahme,
weil er ist ja nicht schwer krank.
Aber wir haben viele, also ich habe Patienten, die mit schweren,
lebensbedrohlichen Erkrankungen zu uns kommen,
der gräbste krank zum Beispiel.
Und diese Leute, die wissen, dass ihre Prognose schlecht ist
und verfüllen manchmal oder verfassen eine Patienten-Verfügung.
Die kann man sich auch im Internet runterladen.
Es gibt Vorlagen dafür, da steht drin, was man in einem Fall der Fälle,
zum Beispiel wenn ich jetzt bewusstlos umfalle,
oder irgendwie Schlaganfall bekomme, was der Patient möchte
und was er nicht möchte.
Manche möchten zum Beispiel nicht wieder reanimiert werden.
Manche möchten, wenn es keine Hoffnung,
auch Verbesserung gibt, an die Maschine gehängt werden.
Manche möchten keine Dialöse.
Manche möchten keine künstliche Ernährung und, und, und.
Und das sind Sachen, die die Patienten manchmal heutzutage mitbringen
mit so einem Formular, was sie ausfüllen.
Und es ist jetzt so, dass der Arzt nicht daran halten muss,
aber wenn etwas passiert und er macht etwas, was da drin steht,
dass es nicht gewollt wird, dann ist es ein Problem.
Insofern sollte man, wenn der Patient anspricht darauf,
versuchen in die Akte auch einzuarbeiten,
dass man das weiß, was der Patient im Falle,
der Falle passieren kann.
Und dann muss man sagen, dass sie einen Stationen aufnehmen
und in der nächsten Nacht kriegt er eine massive Lungenembolie
und stirbt zum Beispiel.
Da ist reanimationspflichtig.
Da müssen sie wissen, was sie mit so einem Patienten machen.
Das war der Grund, warum ich das mache.
Dann habe ich bestattet.
Danke schön.
Gut, alles klar.
Hallo, einen Kollegen noch, eine Frage.
Ich glaube, das ist wichtig, das haben wir gemacht.
Also ich muss sagen, sprachlich war es sehr gut.
Die konnten auf meine Fragen immer antworten,
das ist auch immer wichtig, ob sie alles auswendig gelernt haben
und ob sie auch andere Fragen, die sie nicht kennen, reagieren können.
Das haben sie gut gemacht, finde ich.
Fachlich sind sie ja neu von der Uni,
deswegen kein Problem, glaube ich.
Ja, ma'am und euch auch.